[Musique]
les shadoks élégie bis qui vivent sur
des planètes différentes ont décidé
d'aller sur la tête mais ce n'était pas
si facile que ça oui oui les shadows que
ressembler à des oiseaux il avait un
deck date et l'heure elle était ridicule
nos minuscules
au début les shadoks pour dde ordinaire
mais comme il avait de trop longue pas
de ces deux là se cassaient maintenant
les shadoks pondent des oeufs ont fait
il y en a deux sortes les oeufs avec les
pieds à bas et les hauts avec les pieds
aux ciseaux là on les envoie de l'autre
côté de la planète
les shadoks sont excessivement méchant
chaque fois qu'ils essaient d'aller sur
la terre avec leur petite elle est vide
alors ça rate
[Musique]